j'appelle pas ça serait pour caen
éventuellement
[Musique]
on propose des massages par monaco
concernant mon son rôle dans un conte m
soit dans le 5e et 150 euros la
demi-heure à l'hôtel et je peux
également faire un duo avec une amie les
écoutez moi je serais pour quand l'un
prestations commencent à partir des 100
euros à la famille aucune percée il est
9h du matin
ces trois mamans viennent de déposer
leurs enfants à l'école elles commencent
leur journée de travail pour deux fils
et
et c'est 150 euros la demi-heure des
belles de jour mère au foyer pour leurs
proches prostituer pour leurs clients
oui ce serait pour caen éventuellement
laetitia labrune a franchi le pas sur
internet il y a huit tombes
aujourd'hui elle a 29 ans c'est l'aîné
de la bande est la plus expérimentée
c'est vrai c'est la première fois que je
veux faire l'amour non je te crois pas
là pour ça j'ai envie de te faire je
suis trop une main qui vous ce désir
j'ai avec moi c'est bien la fellation
nature c'est une journée parfaite et si
vous êtes et et les amendes à la blonde
à 26 ans avant son divorce
c'était une femme au foyer depuis elle
doit se débrouiller seuls 200 pour une
heure et 50 euros de plus si je suis en
compagnie d'une amie pour un duo gfr
comment sa portion de 100 euros pour une
demi heure ou deux repreneurs mises à la
route est la plus jeune la plus
insouciante aussi elle vient d'avoir 24
ans dans le cinquième autour d'elle
peu de gens savent leur manucurés dans
la confidence
ces trois mères célibataires n'ont pas
de protecteurs pas de mac
elles forment une sorte de coopérative
ensemble elles sous louent des
appartements pour répondre aux centaines
de coups de fil qu'elles reçoivent
chaque jour les passes se font toujours
à l'hôtel spa 2010 paulin notre
téléphone pour moi oui à nous comme ça
tout le temps
quand on décide de travailler c'est
comme ça on est à la maison on fait
notre vie normale quand même c'est quoi
votre vie normale comme on ménage les
courses j'ai copié les copains tous les
enfants les enfants du petit danny
d'antan en même temps via loup bonjour
oui c'est 100 euros la demi-heure au
revoir n'ait pas marché aux puces les
gens il sait tout en dégradé mais vous
pouvez pas descendre un peu le prix mais
non je te dirai qui jouera les soldes ce
qu'on arrive des fois je pète un plomb
et les clients ils m'appellent bien
aujourd'hui c'est jour de soldes tient
la prestation est à 80 euros les 200
euros c'est une vente flash ça dure que
cinq minutes
profitez-en parce que ça va il ya tout
plein de cas de figure dans la
prostitution
après ce que j'appelle la [ __ ] de bas
étage celle malheureusement qu'ils ont
pas le choix de travailler sur le
trottoir et celle qu'on est à priori
cacher quoi qu'on travaille en
appartement qu'on n'est pas aux yeux de
tous il ya que deux clients qui nous
voient je veux dire on n'est pas
affichée
regardez moi je suis en mini jupe dans
la rue avec des talons hauts jusqu'à 4
heures du matin non nous on arrête de
faire la [ __ ] à 17 heures à 17 heures on
rentre chez nous on s'occupe de nos
enfants jusqu'au lendemain
et quand on est avec nos enfants on
était notre téléphone c'est fini quoi
c'est on est un peu des schizophrènes
indirectement on à double personnalité
bon alors construit un rendez vous dans
un quart d'heure mais qu'il avait deux
filles pour une demi heure 150 euros 150
[Musique]
mon nom je suis un vrai livre
on
a fait mieux avec le soutif ou samsung
chif j'avais mes chances et une comme
moi si j'enlève mes sous chief il reste
droit c'est normal c'est une somme en
suisse mais ça fait moins de grousset
bouaké mieux sans
[Musique]
ça fait bien moi exit bombardements
faudrait du temps je suis donc super
tout partout non ma femme et moi j'aime
bien être content parce que déjà mis la
montée des rousses
oui j'allais journée du stage allez-vous
se veut aussi
voilà voilà vous le saurez comment avant
d'aller à qui on va découvrir juste je
sais que ça peut être un x bulbe donc je
m'attendais pas les sommets
je crie pas victoire mais sinon je m'en
fous moi je pense donc quand il mange
toujours appréhension que c'est un
malade fou j'ai toujours peur de ça en
fait ce qu on rencontre tellement d des
cassos c'est pourquoi tout ça c'est
parce qu'on n'a pas fait d'études
voilà pourquoi si on avait écouté nos
parents et qu'on avait fait des études
on serait un médecin doit beaucoup à
tout le monde et ont nourri un bon
salaire tous les mois et vous n'aurez
pas ces soucis là c'est vrai certes
certes c'est plus sécurisant pour nom de
travailler en route que travailler
chacune de son côté parce qu'on se dit
quand même ont travaillé en groupes
si ça se passe mal il ya toujours
quelqu'un qui peut faire quelque chose
si pète les plombs et on a toujours une
qui va pouvoir sauver l'histoire
le scénario tandis que si tu es seul
face à se mettre là du seul face à son
destin
ça s'est un jour
vos clients sont issus de quel milieu
social touche dans tous les milieux
sociaux la dame a faim on a reçu un
marteau dans this moi j'ai déjà reçu des
médecins des pompiers des policiers
s'est tous les monstres
le boulanger du coin voilà des mecs de
20 ans qui n'ont pas de copine qui
veulent s'amuser mais eux ils ont eu
leur pays ou alors des mets simplement
vous en ont marre de leur femme alors
ils veulent changer vers ce métier c'est
vraiment de toucher tous les milieux
sociaux que ce soit le plus grand d au
moins se le petit chimiste du coin comme
la dernière fois le course
il venait à peine touchés sont les
limites rappelle ben voilà c'est
vraiment tous les milieux sociaux et les
noms de ces vies
[Musique]
pas de limousine pour les conduire pas
de bulles de champagne ni de
préliminaires ce n'est pas un
rendez-vous mais une passe et quant à
l'hôtel la porte s'ouvre
c'est sur un visage inconnu moi je vois
des hommes arrivés des clients costard
cravate quand tu l'aimés à poil c'est
pas du tout le même homme que tu as vu
arriver costard cravate savage rte par
rapport à comment il est habillé tu vois
sa classe sociale quoi et tu te dis
quand même c'est un honneur quand tu le
vois au lit je te dis mais c'est pas
possible c'est un animal que j'ai eu
dans mon lit c'est un animal c'est plus
un homme
certains clients et se déchaînent études
je suis le voit plupart et si un jour tu
le robot dans la rue quelques parts
connaissance secret il y en a même
quitté moyens naquit - dana fois il ya
un client il est venu avec un gros
bouquet de fleurs je croyais que c'était
pour moi gros bouquet de fleurs comme ça
il y avait chez pas combien de rose je
l'aï trop sympa tu marras a imaginé non
c'est pas pour toi c'est que ma forme je
te jure que c'est vrai je suis resté il
m'a même dit que j'appelle un vase est
stocké parce que comme je veux rester
une heure avec toi j'ai pour quel fan
j'ai rempli je coupais une bouteille
d'evian
je les remplis j'ai mis le bouquet de
fleurs il est en train de nous il est en
train de me b 0 garder ses fleurs
d'actifs pas ce à quoi je me pense quand
même la vie elle est cruelle quoi elles
ont vu ce qu'il a fait sans manger des
fleurs je me dis pauvre femme
pauvre femme
[Musique]
ça passe terminée laetitia fait le vide
pour oublier oublier les corps les
visages les odeurs de ses clients
laëtitia n'a pas le choix son enfant
l'attend et ce soir comme tous les soirs
elle redevient maman
[Musique]
la figure de la prostituée a changé
aujourd'hui
les trottoirs sont presque désert celle
qui reste à faire les cent pas sont le
plus souvent étrangères internet a tout
révolutionné et attire des femmes qui ne
serait peut-être pas passé à l'acte dans
la rue
marla à 24
elle donne ce rendez vous à l'hôtel ses
clients sont des habitués
souvent fortunés
marla et escorte et ne s'en cache pas
dans mon annonce je sais plus j'avais
mis jeune femme douce et sensuelle
chercheurs courtois et respectueux pour
rencontre coquine fait un truc très con
comme ça je sais plus exactement à
étudiante marchait plus et ennemis
étudiante au début mais plus après au
début j'ai dû mettre étudiante ouais
pourquoi il aime bien le côté étudiante
aussi ça c'est pas une pro fait simple
pc études ça va être peut-être qui
voyant la proue ils voyent peut être la
fille un peu froide existantes
c'est que ça marche assez bien de dire
que étudiante
souvent on me donne beaucoup plus jeune
que mon âge et on s'imagine pas ce que
je fais peut-être un peu sage
d'apparence que je puisse avoir quand
même des choix de vie aussi marginaux et
qu'il ressemble pas du tout à un paquet
qui colle pas du tout à ce que je peux
je peux envoyer comme image
[Musique]
avec ses airs de lolita marla à garder
quelque chose de l'enfance
cette enfance qu'elle a pourtant voulu
fuir
c'était une petite fille modèle choyée
par ses parents harcelés par les enfants
[Musique]
fuguent l'acné très très tôt arrive en
6e ont un peu fait baver pour ça ce que
j'avais l'appareil dentaire j'avais des
lunettes
les cheveux gras je me cachais à ceux
des cols roulés mais vraiment et on a
fait assez bavé les filles qu'ils font
juge beaucoup à cette époque la fin au
collège les enfants peuvent être très
méchants entre à dire oh là pas belle
ola pas belle et c'est ça paraît stupide
mais va canton c'est une période où on
se cherche on a besoin de repères et ça
n'a pas été très facile de devoir qu'on
n'était pas acceptée par par ses pairs
[Musique]
marla l'enfant solitaire prend son envol
à 18 ans elle quitte le foyer familial
pour les bancs de sciences po
l'étudiante s'émancipe et multiplie les
amants
signe du destin c'est un mémoire sur la
prostitution étudiante qui fait basculer
sa vie quand j'ai dit à mon prof ça je
m'en rappellerai aussi ok je suis allé
le voir pour lui dire oui
concernant mon d'études sociologiques la
prostitution étudiante j'ai décidé de
faire de l'observation participante par
les yeux en termes sociologiques ça veut
dire je fais la même chose que les
sujets que j'étudie c'est à dire je me
prostitue et des bus a pas d'effet après
les diplômes mais je veux que le mythe
vivant soit accomplie l'a dit si vous
êtes sûr de ce que vous faites je peux
pas être derrière vous pour vous
empêcher donc allez-y
[Musique]
marla se retrouvent dans un bar à
hôtesses avec champagne et services
sexuels
une dizaine d'étudiantes viennent ici
arrondir leurs fins de mois
marla elle n'a pas besoin d'argent elle
cherche juste ses limites
le premier jour du bar je me souviens
quand même que j'avais quand même le
coeur qui bat et un peu de ta
d'excitation et d'appréhension aussi de
meylan quoi je m'embarque mais ça va pas
chez folle vous êtes quand même en train
d'aller vous prostituer pour une étude
ouais ben oui ça c'est vraiment un
passage je vois pas dire je passe du
côté obscur de la force quoi c'est ça y
est j'ai un pied dedans mais rapidement
une semaine après mon arrivée j'ai fait
j'ai eu mon premier client dans le salon
c'est à dire un laitage et ce qui était
drôle c'est que je me rappelle toute ma
vie c'était le 9 mars 2010 et c'était la
veille de mes 20 ans et quand je suis
descendue avec la bouteille il était
minuit passé avec la bouteille et le
client et c'était super sympa parce
qu'ils ont tout ce que l'on anniversaire
et c'est là que ça je me dis waouh je me
sens je me sentais bien la balle
ouais
une première passe qui reste un bon
souvenir marla flirte toujours avec la
provocation ce que j'ai beaucoup
apprécié dans le bar c'est que les
filles tu pars et étudiantes on avait
quasiment tout le même âge tout pris
sous leurs ailes en mode off super une
nouvelle copine
c'est la première fois que je me
trouvais vraiment avec des personnes qui
ne jugeait pas enfin pour ma vie
sexuelle ou pour ce que j'étais qui
quittaient pas été pas dans le jugement
[Musique]
marla s'est trouvé des amis elle ne
reviendra plus en arrière
elle plaque ses études tourner deux
films pornos et quitte grenoble pour
monter à paris
le sexe devient la clé de son
indépendance
à 21 ans marla s'installe comme escorte
aujourd'hui sa petite entreprise est
bien rodé un créneau haut de gamme des
semaines à 2000 euros mais surtout la
liberté de choisir ses rendez vous
oui allô oui alors comme vous en doutez
je propose services d'escort cela peut
aller simple accompagnement rapport plus
intime et dans tous les cas j'accorde
beaucoup d'importance au feeling au
respect je ne reçois pas donc mes tarifs
c'est 250 euros de l'heure est par
contre tout est protégé y compris la
fellation
la chanson c'est la vie c'est la très
bien dans le cadre de mes rendez vous
j'ai besoin de contrôler clairement
c'est moi qui dirige ces maquis donne
mes limites avant et ils sortent pas des
limites que j'ai imposé
ils sortent pas de enfin si j'ai dit on
mais la capote partout on met la capote
par tous il est 10h pratique pas je
pratique pas et qui sait pas de me faire
pratiquer c'est pas possible
est ce que tu crois que malgré tout ce
métier ou par d'une joie d'une fine par
d'une je pense pas que ce soit
systématique je pense pas que ça parte
forcément d'une faille ou d'un trauma ou
quoi que ce soit personnellement
effectivement j'ai une faille plus jeune
et c'est mes choix mais mes choix en
termes de prostitution et de porno ont
été pour moi bien plus efficace que
n'importe quelle thérapie que j'ai pu
faire ça a permis de me réapproprier mon
corps et que tout ce que je fais dans le
cadre de mon travail je le fais de façon
libre et choisit ce qui n'a pas toujours
été le cas c'est pour ça que j'aime
vraiment mon travail
oh
marc la loue son corps comme pour
prouver qu'il lui appartient comme une
affirmation de soi d'une faille
elle a fait un style de vie
elle a aussi des amours très libre
marc la hem une fille et un garçon ce
matin c'est avec lui qu'elle se réveille
un étudiant de 20 ans qui a choisi marc
là en toute conscience
je t'ai rencontré d'une prostituée déjà
tu étais déjà sa copine être arrêtée là
plein d'âme en a qui te l'âge dans tout
les sens de cause suite on a beaucoup de
toi on te connaît son second aux parents
ils savent que votre amoureuse escorte
ryanair est là bien ça foutait manhasset
s'insurge et chatila d'un cran mais je
pense honnêtement que suffisamment
aujourd'hui pour le prendre très bien
mes parents savon et alors baba où tu as
ta mère m'a invité à manger toute
contente elle avait envie de me
connaître pour moi et non pas pour ça
quand jean-luc globalement le sol pointe
inquiétudes qu'ils on essaie de savoir
est ce que ça ne vous protège
sexuellement parce que en effet je suis
au foot et du milieu qui sont
probablement un peu plus exposé la
moyenne vous dites que vos parents ont
très bien vécu en fait marc l'asu
métiers etc
marleix en revanche vos parents ils
vivent très mal et des bobos gauchos
parisien c'est michael essien à nos
ennemis ne vont pas très bien vécu du
tout et comprennent toujours pas comme
beaucoup de gens sur la prostitution il
avait quinze mille préjugés il pensait
que je bossais dans des situations
glauques que j'allais tomber sur des
gens qu'il allait me faire du mal
j'allais avoir des problèmes avec la loi
font du ski qu'elle reste
malheureusement il est en france enfin
oui c'est imaginer plein de trucs parce
que oui il fallait m'ont bien c'est un
manche s'est fait très plaisir aussi
c'est qu'ils s'inquiètent comme des
parents pour leur fille ne voulait pas
que c'est le paquet de problèmes mais
maintenant que je juge ça se passe bien
et que j'en ai pas il s'obstine toujours
à vouloir me faire changer étant qu'ils
lanceront dans cette optique là moi je
vais pas les revoir suis pas du tout la
fille à manger qu'ils auraient espéré
que je sois voilà moi ça m'a fait un peu
chier ouais mais bon je vais pas changer
pour moi
[Musique]
non
marc la passe d'un monde à l'autre
d'amoureuse elle redevient escorte
du haut de ses 24 ans elle a vu défiler
beaucoup d'hommes et leurs secrets les
plus intimes
ils sont nus face à moi qu'ils ont beau
se croire les plus forts de la terre je
suis chef d'entreprise je suis avocat je
suis même je fus des hommes politiques
petit peu et qui là tu t'es juste un
homme nu avec des complexes et était
doute et non je trouve vulnérables mais
c'est une vulnérabilité que je trouve
belle
[Musique]
ce qui est lourd c'est quoi c'est le
tabou sens et la stigmatisation qui
l'autre moi j'en ai marre
enfin personnellement j'en ai j'en ai
marre pas de mon travail des conditions
dans lequel je suis obligée de le faire
en france ça j'en ai ras-le-bol
j'en ai ras le bol de la stigmatisation
j'en ai ras-le-bol que que des gens que
je ne connais ni d'eve ni d'adam se
permettent d'émettre un jugement sur moi
comme s'il me connaissait sur ma vie sur
mon passé sur mes choix
c'est ça que je vis mal et c'est aussi
pour ça que je m'exprime pour expliquer
aux gens que non je ne suis pas folle je
suis pas forcé je suis palin et par
l'argent je veux juste faire mon boulot
avec des droits qui approprié
marla assume sans rien planifié elle
décidera peut-être un jour d'arrêter
pour l'instant elle vit sa vie d'escort
elle la bonne élève qui était programmé
pour faire plaisir à ses parents
[Musique]
entre choisir et subir il y à mille
nuances et le plus souvent c'est la
précarité qui décide
[Musique]
ce tournage à marseille les trois mamans
escorte font des passes pour survivre il
est 8h30
laetitia la brune et la première arrive
des nôtres
elle a besoin d'argent et lui il faut
vite des rendez-vous comptable avait
deux visages
oui allô bonjour monsieur aulas plus bas
mais je suis libre maintenant jusqu'à 17
heures je fais 1 m 72 70 kg 110 b de
poitrine ok au revoir regardez quoi les
gens qui passent
comment ils sont heureux j'ai pas la vie
de merde que j'ai a coûté 2 je regarde
passer ma vie c'est bon ça je vous
regarde passer ma vie
c'est pas un métier où je prends du
plaisir à me lever le matin on me dire
tiens aujourd'hui je vais faire ma
journée de huit heures ce que je fais là
c'est honnête puisque je vois mon corps
mais pour moi c'est pas de l'argent
propre
quand je le dépense cet argent là
quelque part j'ai le coeur qui déchire
et parce que je me dis l'argent que je
dépense c'est grâce à ton cul je la
gagne est commencé pour quelque chose
d'aussi ans oui il faudra il faudrait
appeler des masques et s'il vous plaît
il faudrait de rappeler démasqué parce
que je réponds bah en appel masqué merci
au revoir je récolte toute la misère
sexuelle du monde des gens qu'ils sont
pas bien dans leur tête c'est bon quoi
jeanny marc à un moment donné même pour
de l'argent c'est rude d'accepter tout
ce que j'accepte tout petit imaginer
comment quand tu es petit tu disais je
veux faire quoi comme métier j'ai jamais
eu de rêve puisque la vialette jour de
ma vie c'est comme ça tout ça il faut de
tout pour faire un monde
deux des voleurs et des menteurs et les
braqueurs et à des [ __ ] c'est comme ça
jal en vue pour encaisser les coups durs
heureusement qu'il y à l'amitié
oui c'est ça ou la demi heure avec ma
copine et pour 50 euros de plus je peux
éventuellement vous proposer une amie à
moi en tout cas très charmant qui on
dirait des ados en balade
[Musique]
et pourtant elles ont déjà vécu deux vit
en lui fria pas sur le marché du post un
site ami il n'y a pas de liste et c'est
donc bon on va prendre à vous elle loue
à shine dans l'aveyron le but de relever
les enfants comme ça ça leur fera une
activité activité villages de poisson
c'est quoi ce week-end c'est rien ça ya
pas d activité
qu'est-ce que ça râle aux sinistrés le
goûter ou un bon film mais il y en a des
moyens non un beau film pour enfants
jarre c'est le truc à part les torpiller
une femme coincée à wayne batman
spiderman ya pas de rendre à des rendez
vous trop non plus faudrait déjà gagner
souvent dans une même phrase leurs devis
se bousculent escorte et maman comment
peut-on être si différentes et si normal
à la fois lisa la rousse était encore
vendeuse il ya deux ans la vérité je
gagne pratiquement une semaine le
salaire peut se gagner 1200 euros par
mois en travaillant déclaré au smic et
j'ai pas fait d'études donc je n'ai pas
la possibilité de gagner plus dans la
vie j'ai pas je fais cette solution par
facilité en fait c'est une facilité
c'est ça m'apporte de pouvoir donner à
mon enfant tout le temps tout l'amour et
tout aussi l'aspect voilà financier à
voir le frigo grand petite route en
permanence jamais galerie parce que
voilà j'ai eu des périodes de galère
dans ma vie ou même si je travaillais
les scènes de moi c'était durabilité et
tout alors que la trop le cas et ton
enfant tu as peur qu'ils l'apprennent
qu'il te juge un jour ce qui me ferait
peur
par exemple ça me briserait vraiment le
coeur que il
10 par exemple je redis ma mère pour ça
ça oui ça ça serait un très gros drame
de ma vie je crois avec des enfants qui
grandissent garder le secret devient
difficile un entre deux entre le silence
et la veux quand tu m'as rende mon avis
on est en train de travailler
oui je l'appellerai la classe de
découverte en a je peux l'appeler ainsi
fois que c'est parfait allez à tout à
l'heure mon bébé l'algérie
maltem très forte bise ou pas très juste
au moment de poule je les aime plus que
tout ça c'est pas je n'aime plus que
tout mais ça me fait de la peine de tout
ce qui me donne comme amour parce que
des fois une morgane du match et la
meilleure c'est une chose qui me dit ça
parce que moi je sais c'est pour mon
travail j'ai l'impression j'ai
l'impression de le trahir
je rentre le soir je me sens pas très
bien quoi c'est sûr qu'entre nation
c'est 4 5 dans la journée quand tu
rentres chez toi tu pas forcément envie
d'embrasser tourner en forme je me sens
seule loi c-510 bien sûr tout sacrifier
pour ses enfants
les trois mamans escorte sont des
écorchés et quand la conversation
s'attarde d'autres failles se devine jeu
des histoires d'amour ils sont tous
partis avec une autre femme alors vaut
franchement voilà comme patron bien
croire à l'amour donc vous faites un peu
ce job par des pieds un peu moins par
dépit sentimentale ouais par frustration
amoureuse mal c'est simple tu tronic est
gratuite j'ai du mal à nikki gratuit en
fait limite faut vraiment que le mec qui
soit gallen gens qui a le prince
charmant mois pour que vraiment dans mon
corps gratuitement sans compensation
financière
voilà de faire payer des m a fait
plaisir
expliquez-moi votre job - pour moi je
suis comme escorte
je donne des rendez vous j'aime pas le
terme clients et j'aime pas le terme put
les [ __ ] l ont pas de lit de salle de
bain la disposition de bouteilles de
champagne moins une vertu discute où tu
joues un outil garrett avec le mektoub
un café avec lui quand jean [ __ ] c'est
s'est vite vite et tout un truc que
j'avais pas comprendre pourquoi toi tu
te dis tu es tu dis que tu escort-girl
et toi tu dis que tu es [ __ ] mais je
n'arrive pas à faire moins de monde
peut-être mangé une escorte c'est
quelqu'un qui escorte pour moi mais
plein de france s'est disputé sur le
même faire mousser disputé façon de
parler on s'est accrochés sur le même
sujet mais quand tu fais toi la [ __ ] je
fais toi la vie de ces aléas les nazis
des habitants partent - laissons aller
mais c'est revoir les lois mais moi je
préfère un peu plus tranquille aux
annonceurs des amis veut et wave n'est
pas là pour me faire des amis parce que
je veux faire beaucoup d'argent près une
petite camionnette va dans un paysage
bien qu'ils prennent tous leur niche et
là bas ou d'incinérer d'autoroute est un
gars tu te feras disponible à je sais
que suis en train de t'énerver mais
monde est nerveux pas mais si je te
connais mais je vais très la vérité je
m'énerve pas je vais te faire dire la
vie ribéry je la vérité moi je pars du
principe que les clients c'est pas mes
amis je suis pas là pour nous faire le
mobile est là pour ce faire l'illusion
qu'il est en grande et vous galant j'ai
l'impression que ce mental mais le
métier de prostituée ou d'escort c'est
pareil à quelques différences près bien
sûr y'a plein de catégories de [ __ ] de
la burqa la classe j'applique à la
crasse le métier d'une vaste chef celle
qui fait ça dans les grands hôtels dans
qui voyagent qui leurs clients les
emmène de partout avec eux alors que ses
députés sont payés pour ça
en fait tu finis toujours par écarter
les jambes que tu le veuilles que tu
veuilles pas quand tu danses medshare
coaching de luxe que cheng plus de bas
étage le final c'est le même c'est comme
un film à la fin il ya toujours terne
il ya des escaliers un travail à finir
d'écriture ou de géométrie tu lui fais
juste une jcct tête avec les mots du
petit cahier et les mots outils et tout
ce qu'il a fait fondre dans la dictée
bel effet bien lire comme ça il est en
ville
dionne il refait avec le modèle la
correction quand une fine ligne de
chaque mot clé font les escortes se
cachent pour les trouver il faut
chercher du côté des plus fragiles les
étudiantes par exemple loyer frais de
scolarité leur budget a explosé depuis
dix ans certaines passent à l'acte
combien sont-elles en france 500 5000
plus encore pour c'est occasionnel
il n'y a pas de statistiques margot est
l'une de ces invisibles
tout commence il ya six ans elle est en
deuxième année de droit
ses parents ne peuvent pas suivre
[Musique]
j'avais l'impression qu'en fait on
n'allait pas réussir à vraiment à passer
cette période où je pensais que j'allais
pas pouvoir faire d'études et que
j'allais devenir caissière toute ma vie
alors que c'était pas du tout ce que ce
que je voulais faire de ma vie bien un
moment que j'ai eu deux boulots où je
travaillais le soir en tant que tel dans
un restaurant non quand je finisse à 2
heures du matin pour ensuite enchaîner
les cours le lendemain et que et je
gardais les enfants par exemple le
mercredi toute la journée mais du coup
je devais manquer les propos c est tout
ça parce qu'il fallait que j'aie de
boulot pour que je puisse couper margot
rate sa deuxième année de droit
un jour une amie lui parle d'une
solution inavouables faire financer ses
études par des hommes d'affaires
il suffit de s'inscrire sur un site et
se montrer gentil avec son ange gardien
je me souviens encore comme si c'était
hier le le premier homme qui m'a
qui m'a donné une enveloppe avec 600
euros de dons en espèces pour moi
c'était un mois de salaire de job job
étudiant alors que là en une soirée
j'étais dans un des meilleurs
restaurants de paris que je vois que du
luxe autour de moi et qu'en plus j'ai
600 euros dans ma poche
oui je sors contente de ce genre de
rendez vous et c'est un peu près tu te
demande rien en échange
alors en vrai que il y en aura une autre
un autre type de relation ce ne serait
pas quel type de relation basse et je le
peux je vais pas dire une relation
amoureuse c'est pas une relation
amoureuse mais aux relations intimes
choisir
[Musique]
margot tourne autour des mots elle dit
sans dire un verre un dîner parfois plus
avec des hommes qui pourrait être son
père
ils ont de l'argent de l'expérience ils
connaissent les usages magot se laisse
guider
ça sera je pense à jamais dans ma
mémoire de d'arriver dans un restaurant
où vraiment comme à la télé où ils vont
prendre un veste ou où tu vas t'asseoir
ils vont ils vont bouger ta chaise dès
que tu va aux toilettes et accompagne
août à 12 couverts et tu sais même pas
par quelle pouvait recommencer
ce qui est bien c'est que avec 4,5
rendez vous par mois
c'est enfin j'ai géré ses preuves j'ai
même plus pour le mois
[Musique]
attirés par les lumières est accrochée à
ses études
margot avance du restaurant
universitaire aux tables étoilées de son
petit deux pièces aux plus grands hôtels
[Musique]
sont en train de vie augmente elle entre
dans une spirale et quand elle est dans
le rouge
elle accepte tous les rendez vous je me
souviens de darna en particulier me
proposer mille deux cents euros je
devais deux mois de loyer donc je décide
d'accepter la réalisation d'hôtels était
vraiment pas beau je me dis dans ma tête
c'est pas grâce à passer visite j'ai
besoin de cet argent donc hélas j'en
suis senti très sale eux je suis parti
dans la salle de bains pleurer pourquoi
vous plaît parce que je me suis sentie
j'avais l'impression que j'avais plus
cette valeur en moi en tant que que
femme libre j'avais que j'ai dû faire
quelque chose qui me plaisait pas
forcément et que excepté s'était pas
apprécié du tout je me suis là je me
suis je veux dire je me suis vraiment
forcer
[Musique]
ces mauvaises rencontres il faut bien
les enfouir les emporter avec soi
margot ne peux en parler à personne
elle vit seule pas d'histoire d'amour
peu d'amis margot l'occasionnel se coupe
du monde
on n'a pas forcément une vie comme tout
le monde je ne pouvais pas avoir de
relation amoureuse stable parce que
sinon je devais mentir tout le temps est
vraiment parce que j'avais besoin
d'aller à ces rendez vous vous sentez
retraça les halls et l'isolément de
toute façon c'est sûr parce que à partir
du mans on garde un secret pour mon
épouse raconte ça à personne etc en plus
à un secret de tous les jours on sera
forcément isolé qui est allé j'avais
très peu
c'est pourquoi je me suis acheté un
chien ce que je retrouve par exemple moi
c'était ma façon de de pouvoir en ce
manque d'affection peut-être ce ce
manque d'amitié et bon jeu le jeu je
peux le prouver enfin ça reste un chien
mais bon au moins je je le sens que j'ai
de l'affection par rapport à mon chien
par exemple
donc c'est ce que j'ai fait quand je me
sentais très seul vous pensez que vous
allez réussir à arrêter
depuis l'année dernière j'ai beaucoup
diminué parce que comme je vais bientôt
rentrer dans le monde actif du travail
jeu que j'arrête ou non un peu à peu que
j'ai moins d'entrées d'argent
donc quand j'essaie de diminuer le plus
possible les rendez vous pour pouvoir me
habitués on voit avoir un travail et
puis et puis vivre sans forcément un
gage leur demandaient
[Musique]
margot a fait les choses à l'envers
elle termine ses études et cède avance
qu'elle gagnera moins d'argent demain
avec ses premiers salaires
c'est quoi vos rêves pour vous dans
vingt ans c'est bon jeu j'aimerais avoir
un bon poste
on va avoir des enfants
un ou deux je sais pas en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est que dès que j'aurai un
poste je mettrais de côté pour mes
enfants plus tard qu'ils puissent faire
leurs études sans devoir faire le genre
de choses que moi j'ai dû faire
[Musique]
la jeune femme rêve de revenir à une vie
sans âge
[Musique]
mais il y a des parenthèses qu'il est
compliqué de refermer
[Musique]
oh
elle
[Musique]
oui allô n'ont-ils bonjour monsieur oui
ça serait pour qu'en arrivant tuellement
oui c'est ça on roule à de meilleurs
[Musique]
ce matin-là à marseille les trois mamans
escorte travail leur image
pour attirer le client elles changent
régulièrement leur amour comme roux max
et sur internet
la photo est cruciale l'échantillon est
oui ah voilà comme ça elle est trop
belle
ce jeu voilà à essaie de te mettre c'est
ça qu'ils aiment les hommes il aime et
filles sexy sexy d'être sexy de
maquiller les atouts en valeur
non mais faut pas que ce soit dénudées
il faut que les photos soient sens pour
que même s'ils n'ont elles sont pas
acceptés sur le site
pourquoi parce que c'est pas des sites
officiellement le d'escort on n'a pas le
droit de mettre des photos les faits
qu'ils vivent
oui à dos assez bon tu vois ma clé sous
tes cinq minutes je t'ai dit non ils
apprennent ils savent même pas que c'est
payant
j'ai besoin je l'écouté parce que depuis
ce matin j'ai reçu au moins 80 appelle
enfin seul rendez-vous concret sept
jours elles vont partir en rangs des
bulls - j'ai pas fait un seul rendez
vous je vais rentrer bredouille chez moi
sont ses chiens
laëtitia a moins de clients est ce parce
qu'elle est ronde où la plus âgée elle
n'a pourtant pas 30 ans
mais le métier d'escort abymes et la loi
de l'offre et de la demande est cruel
mettant davantage en valeur
c'était un avantage que tu retiens un
gros cul tu as des gros seins tu sais
d'eux
de mettre ça en valeur sans mettre ton
double montant du manque de confiance en
toi en fait je manque de pour te mettre
en valeur il est bien à la déviance
m'appliquer bien elle l est pas trop
belle si joyeux pour eux de faire la
[ __ ] parce que comme elles sont jeunes
le font ça avec des jeunes dont les
pressions voilà mais quand j'arrive à
mon âge tous décrits comme des grands
sportifs un certain âge ça y est on est
plus à la page parce que dans ce métier
ne râle les gens ils veulent bien payer
mais pour de la chair fraîche comme on
dit vulgairement
ça y est passé 30 ans est morte pour on
oublie tout
et après tout les lingettes mois le beau
temps au téléphone
oui tout bon c'est moi c'est ta
maîtresse gm vie d'un chien je sais
mais adama fall était bien corriger ça
veut dire avoue du même ordre
ça m'ennuie je vais me faire obéir
t'inquiète pas tu vas te prendre des
coups de savates
tu vois la niche là jusqu'à demain ouais
pas bouger demain mais bizarrement ces
insoumis en fait mais insoumis qui se
prend pour un chien en fait est un vrai
chien
il aimerait que je lui mette la laisse
que je le promène au milieu des vrais
gens que je lui lance un ballon qui
veulent chercher ou quoi que ce soit où
que je le frappe comme un chien comme m
après son chien quand il fait quelque
chose de mal mais moi ça me dérange pas
de faire ça mais d'un côté ça me dérange
ça me
ça me gêne en fait d'un côté j'ai de la
peine pour lui j'ai vraiment de la peine
pour lui quoi ah ben ça c'est un nombre
tout à fait normal tout à fait normal il
est prof dans les écoles il s'occupe de
plein d'enfants ces nombres tout à fait
normal et son kiff c'est d'être soumis
une haine il a une famille là des
enfants il a une maison une piscine puis
là le cliché cheap de l'homme totalement
intégrés dans la société quoi est elle a
pas à côté de ça il a une vie parallèle
que voilà c'est bizarre
[Musique]
ainsi va la vie de laetitia oui ça
serait pour caen éventuellement un
mandat et lisa j'ai de très jolis pieds
je fais du 36 à je pense que je vous ai
déjà eu en plus vous trois escortes
étrangement normal mais je change qui
demande de prêt n'ont donc après trouvé
trois femmes d'aujourd'hui à la [ __ ]
de vie ben alors rappeler quelqu'un
d'autre des annonces spéciales pourtant
au revoir
[Musique]